first we do have a developing story here
at five
where two babies are dead near desert
inn and maryland parkway
that's where we find kate houston with
the latest for us kate
yes police are describing this as a
horrific scene they say
that a one-year-old and a two-month-old
are dead their father found them inside
of an apartment complex
just behind me here now this is still
an active scene with police
investigating caution tape is blocking
off
much of this street tonight according to
police the father came home
and found the two children in the corner
of the living room
he saw that they were dead and called
9-1-1 when officers arrived they tried
to revive the one-year-old but it was
too late
i'm told the children's mother was
arrested and booked on two counts of
open murder
earlier today i spoke to a neighbor who
saw police arrive and says the father
was extremely upset
they say it's scary and sad to know what
happened inside
my heart goes out to the family my heart
goes out to the surviving family
and you know i just i just hope we don't
have something like that happen again
there i want
those kids to be able to play and have a
good time in that apartment complex
at this time there is no motive for the
deaths back out here live
police will be here for several more
hours as they investigate
there's no word on the identity of the
mother or the children
nor how the children died reporting live
from sierra vista and maryland parkway
tonight kate houston 8 news now